Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Kapagann. Ich bin hier als Dienstabendarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anämpfnese gesprochen führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mir Bescheid sagen.
Okay.
Ja, okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Sebastian Bitner.
Sebastian Bitner, könnten Sie bitte hier ein Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, Bitner schreibt sich B-I-T-T-N-E-R. Bitner.
Bitner, okay. Herr Bitner, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre.
63 Jahre, okay. Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 26.04.1959.
1949.
1950.
Okay. Herr Bitner, wie weit sind Sie?
80 Kilo.
80 Kilo, okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 Meter.
Ja, 80.
Okay, Herr Bitner, was führt Sie zu uns? Was für welche, welche Berne momentan haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe so seit gut einem Tag, anderthalb Tagen habe ich zunehmende Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, und jetzt sind die so stark geworden.
Da hat meine Frau gesagt, jetzt musst du ins Krankenhaus.
Ja, das ist gut, dass sie hier gekommen sind.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Ja, am Anfang waren die mehr so links im Bauch, so links in der Mitte.
Jetzt tut der ganze Bauch weh.
Ja, okay.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sie sind mehr so drückend, aber Sie kommen und gehen, Sie sind so wellenförmig.
Alle paar Minuten kommen so ein ganz starker Schmerz und dann dauert das etwas und dann lässt er wieder langsam etwas nach und dann kommt er wieder.
Okay, genau, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen plus aufgetreten oder langsam?
Die sind langsam aufgetreten.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala beschreiben?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichte und 10 sehr starker Schmerzen meint?
Also ich würde sagen, jetzt gerade sind sie vielleicht 5 bis 6, aber wenn so eine Welle kommt, dann sind sie eher bei 8.
Okay, genau, ja.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie etwas ausprobiert, um diese Schmerzen zu linden?
Ja, ich habe mal eine Wärmflasche draufgelegt auf dem Bauch.
Das hat aber nichts Wesentliches verändert.
Ja, okay.
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Schmerzen?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Seit einem Tag haben Sie diese Schmerzen und Sie sind zu uns gekommen, nicht bei anderen Ärzten oder so, bei Hausarzt.
Ich bin direkt jetzt zu Ihnen.
Strahlen die Schmerzen in andere bestimmte Körperteile aus?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Die sind im Bauch.
Okay.
Und jetzt im ganzen Bauch, haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Jetzt sind sie im ganzen Bauch.
Der Bauch fühlt sich relativ dick an.
Sonst habe ich nicht so einen dicken Bauch, so prall.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diesen dicken Bauch?
Ja, mehr jetzt so, vielleicht seit 7-8 Stunden.
8 Stunden, okay.
Haben Sie Fülle geführt oder Belehrungen?
Also, ich muss häufiger aufstoßen und habe aber etwas Brechreiz.
Aber ich habe noch nicht erbrochen.
Ja.
Aber ist Ihnen übel, ja?
Ich habe auch keinen Appetit, weil es so weh tut.
Genau.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Appetit haben.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit umgehört ab oder zugenommen?
Ja, in den letzten 6-8 Wochen habe ich so circa 5 kg verloren, angewicht.
8 Wochen, ja.
5 kg ungefähr, ja.
Aber ich habe keine Diät gemacht.
Irgendwie wurde es weniger.
Ja, obwohl Ihr Appetit normal ist, ja, damals in dieser letzten Zeit?
Ja, genau.
Meiner der Appetit war noch ganz normal.
Okay.
Trotzdem haben Sie in der letzten Zeit 5 kg abgenommen.
Ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie auch keinen Fieber haben, ja?
Fieber habe ich nicht, nee.
Okay.
Und haben Sie nicht erbrochen?
Ist die nicht schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir nicht.
Sie haben auch saures Aufstoßen, ja?
Ja, so etwas Aufstoßen habe ich und auch Luft.
Ja, aber erbrochen ist nicht.
Ja, leider sind sie unter Sortbrennen.
Normaler nicht, nein.
Okay, keine Sortbrennen.
Und haben Sie gestern etwas spalysierte Essen gegessen,
dass diese in diesem Zusammenhang mit diesem Schmerzen gibt?
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Also, wenn ich etwas Falsches gegessen habe oder so,
das würde ich anders merken, dann würde ich vielleicht erbrechen
oder habe vielleicht Durchfall, dann habe ich nicht.
Okay, ja.
Und ich würde fragen, sind diese Schmerzen laugeabhängig
oder narusabhängig oder bewegungsabhängig,
wenn sie bewegen sich?
Das tut dann so weh, da bewege ich mich nicht groß.
Da lege ich mich lieber auf Sofa und ziehe die Knie etwas an.
Das ist vielleicht etwas angenehmer.
Aber groß bewegen will ich mich nicht, weil das auch so weh tut.
Ja, okay.
Husten Sie?
Ja, so ein bisschen Husten habe ich, aber ich rauche nicht,
aber ich habe nichts Übermäßiges.
Nein.
Und seit wann haben Sie die Husten?
Nein, ich sage, ich hauste nicht sehr stark.
Aber im Augenblick sind ja auch viele Menschen erkältet.
Vielleicht habe ich im Augenblick eine ganz leichte Pontitis,
aber das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Okay, alles klar.
Und leider schüttet Frust, Nachtschweiß oder Luftmord.
Nein.
Oder Herzrasen, Herzstolpern?
Ne, habe ich auch nicht. Herzrasen, Herzstolpern habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Also Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung, ich muss einmal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen,
aber das ist schon seit einigen Jahren so.
Und Stuhlgang ist allerdings in letzter Zeit etwas schwieriger.
Sonst habe ich immer regelmäßig Stuhlgang.
Und jetzt in letzter Zeit vielleicht nur alle zwei Tage.
Und seit gestern Morgen habe ich gar keinen Stuhlgang.
Ah, okay.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte diesen Stuhl beschreiben?
Ist fest oder wässrig?
Oder haben Sie durch?
Ergibt Sie, dass Sie keine Stuhlgang beschreiben?
Stuhlgang ist eher ein bisschen so schleimig.
Ja, aber früher war der Stuhlgang besser.
Früher war es mehr, auf einmal.
Jetzt ist das weniger.
Genau, aber haben Sie keine Unabhängigkeit?
Ja, ich meine jetzt frisches Blut im Stuhl.
Hab ich nicht gesehen, aber ich habe seit gestern Morgen ja auch keinen Stuhlgang.
Keinen Stuhlgang, okay.
Leider ist unter Verstufung?
Normalerweise nicht, aber in den letzten Wochen ist, wie gesagt,
da hat sich etwas verändert beim Stuhlgang.
Er ist seltener.
Genau, ja.
Seit letzter Woche.
Ja, seitdem ich in der Nacht war,
ja, genau, ja.
Seit letzter Woche.
Nein, das ist schon seit einigen Wochen.
Seit gestern Morgen, seit gestern habe ich...
Genau, ja, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Stuhlgang, aber haben Sie keine Schmerzen beim Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise nicht, ne?
Das ist alles klar.
Herr Bittner, jetzt möchte ich etwas zu Ihrer kranken Geschichte fragen.
Leiden Sie eine bestimmte Vorerkrankung,
von der ich wissen sollte, z.B.
Blutzuckerkrankheit, Blutverordrück oder Leberkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe hohes Cholesterin.
So seit zehn Jahren, und dann nehme ich eine Tablette.
Ja, zehn Jahre.
Was ist die Tablette, nehmen Sie?
Die heißt Rosovastatin.
Ja.
10 Milligramm, nehme ich eine am Abend.
Eine am Abend, okay.
Und dann habe ich auch noch so seit circa drei Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Ja, okay.
Dann nehme ich auch Tabletten ein.
Welche Tablette nehmen Sie ein?
Visoprolol, fünf.
15 Milligramm.
Eine morgens.
Okay.
Und Ramipril.
Ramipril.
Fünf.
Eine morgens und eine halbe Abends.
Halbe Abends.
Okay.
Ansonsten nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ein, oder?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Ansonsten haben Sie auch keine Vorerkrankungen.
Weil das bis jetzt wissen Sie.
Ich bin als Kind operiert worden.
Und hatte vor fünf Jahren hatte ich eine Nierensteinzertrümmerung.
Und danach war das aber gut.
Okay.
Die Operation, Welchoperation, wo Sie?
Ja, ich habe das in der Mitte, da war ich zehn Jahre alt, da hatte ich eine blinde Operation.
Okay.
Und vor fünf Jahren haben Sie eine Nierensteinleiden.
Ja, da ist der Nierensteinzertrümmerung geworden.
Ja, okay.
Mit einer Therapie, mit einem Behandlung.
Ja, ein Apparat, der das Stoß wählen.
Genau.
Stoßwählen, ja, Stoßwählen.
Und jetzt haben Sie keine Beschwerden.
Das wird immer mal kontrolliert, aber das ist in Ordnung.
Okay, das ist schön.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Allergien habe ich nicht.
Kein allergisch, gut.
Sind Ihnen Unfalltätigkeiten bekannt?
Nein, ich vertrage alles.
Das ist gut.
Lauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends so zum Abendessen eine Flasche Bier.
Abends eine Flasche Bier, okay.
Bier, okay.
Ansonsten keine andere, okay.
Nehmen Sie Drogen, das ist eine standardmäßige Frage, eine medisiche Frage an Sie?
Nein.
Keine Drogen, okay.
Herr Bittner, ich muss jetzt fragen,
haben Sie das stark geschmärzten oder können Sie ertragen,
bis das geschmärzende ist?
Ja, das geht.
Das war vorhin gerade wieder so eine Welle da, aber das geht jetzt noch.
Das kann ich noch warten.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und wie ist die Impfstattung?
Impfen.
Die Hausarzt sagt, das ist alles soweit gut.
Ich bin dreimal gegen Covid geimpft.
Und die anderen Impfungen, die hier in Europa notwendig sind
und sinnvoll sind, die habe ich.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
In trokischen Regionen, in Afrika oder so?
Nein, ich war nur mal eine Woche in Frankreich.
Am Meer, in der Britannien, aber sonst nicht.
Okay, in Frankreich.
Wann ist das?
Vor acht Wochen.
Vor acht Wochen, okay.
Aber haben Sie nicht Spassieres dort auch gegessen?
Eigentlich davor acht Wochen,
das ist auch kein Problem für uns, für diese Schmerzen.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, früher habe ich Fußball gespielt
und Handball, aber in den letzten 20 Jahren habe ich keinen Sport hergemacht.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, Herr Bitna, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familienanamnese
und über Ihre privates Leben sprechen, fragen, an sich stellen.
Und wie ist die Familie dort?
Ich bin verharadet.
Ja, genau, Sie haben gesagt schon.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind 32 und 30 Jahre alt.
Die 32-jährige Tochter hat eine Darmentzündung.
Jetzt, momentan.
Chronische Darmentzündung, oder?
Ja, eine chronische Darmentzündung wird mit Medikamenten behandelt
und im Augenblick ist das sehr gut eingestellt, sehr stabil.
Okay, aber Sie nehmen, legen Sie Medikamente ein, momentan.
Medikamente?
Im Augenblick nicht auf den Namen der Medikamente, kann ich Sie nicht sagen.
Okay, eine Tochter und einen Sohn haben Sie?
Der Sohn ist gesund.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, 59 Jahre alt, der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Okay, das ist auch Medikamentus eingestellt, oder?
Ja, der nimmt auch eine Tablette, aber ich kann Ihnen auch nichts sagen.
Genau, ja, okay, alles klar.
Und mit wem wohnen Sie zusammen?
Mit meiner Frau.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Okay, und gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie,
von denen ich zum Beispiel Blutdruck oder Blutzuckerkrankheit,
oder Leberkrankheit oder Dankkrankheit?
Der Vater ist mit 86 Jahren verstorben an einem Schlaganfall.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen, das habe ich nicht.
Der Vater ist verstorben an einem Schlaganfall.
89 Jahre alt, ja?
68 Jahre alt, ja.
Als er 60 Jahre alt war, hatte er Darmkrebs.
Okay, er hatte 60 Jahre alt, ja?
Er war 60, da ist er operiert worden und ist danach alles gut.
Okay.
Und die Mutter, die lebt noch, mit, die ist 88 Jahre alt.
Die hat ja Knochenverschleis, Arthrose und Herzschwäche.
Okay, okay.
Und ansonsten keine wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Nein, sonst fällt mir nichts ein.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie als beruflich?
Ich bin Rechtsanwalt.
Rechtsanwalt, ja.
Sind Sie damit zufrieden bei der Arbeit, oder?
Ja, es ist viel zu tun, ich muss viel arbeiten, aber es macht mir auch immer noch Spaß.
Ja, das ist gut, ja. Das wünsche ich auch.
Und haben Sie momentan Stress?
Ja, etwas Stress haben wir immer, aber nicht besonders viel.
Okay, das ist gut, ja.
Und die Menschen, die jede Mensch hat natürlich manchmal Stress, das ist auch normal für die Gesellschaft.
Können Sie gut schlafen, einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, das geht, da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Okay, das ist schön.
Und Sie haben in dieser Beschwerde, haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie manchmal in der Nacht Wasser lassen müssen?
Ja, einmal in der Nacht muss ich aufstehen und Wasser lassen.
Genau.
Dann kann ich aber wieder gut einschlafen.
Ja, außer diese Nährensteinleiden, haben Sie andere Nährenerkrankungen?
Nein, das ist kontrolliert worden beim Urologen.
Der Urologer sagt nur, die Prostata ist etwas vergrößert, das muss ich nachts einmal Wasser lassen.
Okay, ein bisschen vergrößert.
Und leiden Sie unter Yukreis oder Hautverfärbung, haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein, was wichtig sein könnte?
Ja, ich habe natürlich die Frage, was kann ich haben, was kann das sein?
Ja, okay, jetzt erkläre ich Ihnen, was wir machen werden und was zu tun ist.
Herr Bidna, so erst müssen Sie natürlich hier bei USP-Labit für weitere Untersuchungen und Behandlungen.
Bisher haben wir eine nächste Gespräche gemacht und von meiner Seite habe ich alle wichtige Fragen an Sie gestellt.
Jetzt kann ich Ihnen nur zu wenig sagen, leider muss ich ein paar Untersuchungen auch durchführen
und mit dem Oberarzt sprechen. Danach komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und sage Ihnen, wie wir vorgehen können.
Okay.
Aber jetzt, vielleicht haben Sie eine Darmerkrankung, oder könnte es sein eine Lebererkrankung,
auch könnte es sein, oder Steinleiden, oder eine Nierensteinleiden, das auch möglich.
Und ich möchte auch eine Frage an Sie stellen. Leiden Sie unter Gerbsut oder ja in Ihren Augen haben Sie bemerkt,
oder in Ihren Hautbeerfahrungen haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, aber ich habe mir nicht aufgefallen, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay, das war meine Frage und danke Ihnen.
Ich möchte noch einmal fragen, Sie könnten seit gestern nicht Zugang gehen,
aber haben Sie üreniert, mit dem Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen geht, ja, das geht.
Und oder gehen Wind ab?
Nicht so richtig. Es kommt mehr Luft nach oben raus.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen werden für mich als Attacke kommen.
Wie lange halt eine Attacke an und wie oft kommt es zu einer Attacke heute?
Ja, ich habe vorhin so gesagt, das kommt zu alle paar Minuten, vielleicht zu alle fünf bis zehn Minuten
und das dauert so zwei Minuten, so eine Welle, ein bis zwei Minuten vielleicht, aber ja, so ungefähr.
Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber es sind dann Pausen,
die Welle ist dann wieder weniger, aber es ist immer ein Schmerz da.
Wenn Sie Bauchschmerzen bekommen als Attacke,
ist es noch etwas zur selben Zeit, zum Beispiel in der Tachikarte, Luftnoten oder...
Nein, habe ich nichts anderes. Es ist dann dieser Schmerz, aber der ist dann sehr stark, wenn dieser Attacke kommt.
Okay, meine Seite.
Unsere Kollegen hat Fragen noch.
Wenn wir dem in Alsars gespielt haben, können wir anfangen.
Okay.
Hallo Herr Oberast, hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Ja, ich habe nur ganz wenig Zeit, Sie müssen mir ganz kurz und knapp sagen, was ist das für ein Patient?
Okay, jetzt mache ich ganz schnell und Herr Sebastian Bitner,
ein 63 Jahre alt und 80 Kilogramm schwer und 1,84 cm groß.
Ja.
Herr Sebastian Bitner hat sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern bestehender Bauchschmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen befinden sich am Anfang im linken Seite,
danach jetzt im Ganzenbauch, befinden sich im Ganzenbauch
und die Schmerzen seien plösisch aufgetreten,
und werden für mich,
der Patient hat die Schmerzen als drückend beschrieben
und der Patient habe Warnfläche ausprobiert, um diese Schmerzen zu linden,
aber das habe nichts gebracht, Verbesserung gebracht.
Okay, hat der Patient erbrochen?
Nein, er hat nicht erbrochen, nur Brechreis gehabt,
und es gibt auch keine Ausstrahlung,
und jetzt hat der Patient bestehender ganz Bauchschmerzen.
Und wann war der letzte Stuhlgang bei den Patienten?
Der letzte Stuhlgang seit gestern Morgen habe er keine Stuhlgang,
und der Stuhlgang sei schleimig,
und habe auch kein Blut im Stuhl bemerkt.
Jetzt in letzter Zeit sei der Stuhl schleimig,
oder weil er seit gestern keinen Stuhl hat?
Genau, seit gestern kein Stuhl, vorher hat er diese schleimige Stuhl bemerkt.
Gibt es da in letzter Zeit eine Veränderung im Stuhlgang?
In letzter Zeit nur diese schleimige Stuhl habe er bemerkt,
aber andere Auffälligkeit gebe es keine.
Hat der Patient sein Gewicht gehalten?
Seit Gewicht, ja, er hat bemerkt, er habe bemerkt,
dass in den letzten acht Wochen fünf Kilogramm abgenommen,
und obwohl sein Appetit in der letzten Zeit normal ist,
und er habe auch kein Fieber, und er habe auch Nükturi,
und leide unter einer Nüktur,
und die Schmerzinterestet liegen auf einer Schmerzschalaphone,
ein bisschen beim fünf und sechs, jetzt,
aber wenn Schmerzattacken kommt, bei acht,
und seit acht Stunden habe der Patient ein Wickenbauch bemerkt,
und früher habe er auch keine ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt,
und früher habe er auch nicht andere Arzt aufgesucht
wegen dieser Beschwerden,
und momentan leide klackte der Patient über eine Inapätenz,
und wie gesagt habe Nükturi,
und ja, das war es,
und die Frage nach Fieber, Juckreis und Hautverkärbung
wurden verneidt, die Zürich und auch wurden verneidt,
die restlichen Begetanerungsanläss sind unauffällig.
Ist der Patient voroperiert im Bauch?
Genau, im Bauch, ja,
oder mit zehn Lebensjahren,
seit der Patient operiert worden,
appendoktomiert worden,
aber das war, das war ungefähr 50, 50 Jahren.
Ja, okay, gibt es sonst irgendwelche Operationen
oder Eindrüfe bei den Patienten?
Ja, vor fünf Jahren wurde eine,
wegen einer Niedensteinleitung, Nefolithiasis,
eine Behandelte, wurde behandelt mit Stoßwählen,
der Patient wurde behandelt,
aber jetzt haben erst keine Beschwerden mit dem Niedenstein, Nefolithiasis.
Gut, gibt es Angaben zur Familienanamnese?
Zur Familienanamnese, ja,
und habe erst eine 32-jährige Tochter,
die eine Kdarmerkrankung habe.
Ich vermute, dass eine Morbuskrone ist,
die auch Belutze nehme ein paar Medikamente ein,
aber die Medikamentenliste kennen der Patient nicht.
Okay, gibt es Auffälligkeiten bei den Eltern?
Ja, bei den Eltern, der Vater des Patienten
mit 86 Jahren Lebensjahr,
sei an einer Apoplexie verstorben
und vorher habe der Vater einen Dark Crab
mit 60, 16. Lebensjahr,
und sei operiert worden
und danach war alles unaufgesehen.
Und weshalb ist der operiert worden?
Woran?
Wegen Dark Crab.
Genau, mit Colon Carcinum.
Colon Carcinum, genau.
Gibt es eine positive Familienanamnese?
Genau, positive Familienanamnese
wegen dieser Dark Crab
und bei der Tochter auch eine Darmerkrankung gibt es.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtsdiagnose ist eine,
wegen dieser Predisposonfaktoren,
eine Darmerkrankung, Morbus Crohn,
oder ja, Morbus Crohn,
seit gestern habe der Patient diese Schwelden gehabt,
aber vielleicht eine Beginnende Morbus Crohn können wir sagen.
Und andererseits kann ich auch erwähnen,
dass der Patient eine Nieren-Nepholythiasis habe,
das ist auch möglich.
Eine, zwei Verdachtdiagnose, oder?
Kommt denn auch ein Colon Carcinum in Betracht?
Als die Verdachtsdiagnose, oder?
Als Verdachtsdiagnose, ein Colon Carcinum.
Ja, als Verdachtdiagnose würde ich...
Hallo?
Können Sie mich hören?
Jetzt kann ich Sie wieder hören, ja?
Okay.
Als Verdachtdiagnose kann ich
eine Colon Carcinum sagen.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Colon Carcinum.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen eine Nepholythiasis
und eine Morbus Crohn und Cholestitis-Infrage.
Ja, okay.
Zur weiteren Abklärung werde ich den Patienten
zuerst köpelisch untersuchen,
dann den Patienten Blut abnehmen.
Verschiedene Blutwerte werde ich anschauen,
Serpi und Lebelwerte, Nierenwerte,
Kreatinen, zum Beispiel,
und Lipas, Amylas, Panklaswerte werde ich anschauen.
Und Abdomen-Synographie werde ich durchführen.
Gegenüber eine Röntgen Abdomen werde ich auch veranlassen.
Und Gegenüber Abdomen-Computatomographie City
werde ich auch veranlassen.
Okay, okay.
Ich habe den Patienten einiges doch für ein konsumierendes Leiden.
Er hat eine Gewichtsabnahme,
eine ungewollte Gewichtsabnahme von 5 kg
innerhalb von wenigen Wochen.
Genau, ja.
Dann berichten Sie über schleimigen Stuhlgang
und ein verändertes Stuhlverhalten in den letzten Wochen.
Genau.
Sodass man jetzt fast den Verdacht haben muss
bei der positiven Familienanamnese,
bei dem Alter des Patienten,
dass es sich doch vielleicht um ein Kolonkarzinom handeln kann,
mit der entzündlichen Damerkrankung in dem Alter,
das gibt es auch, aber es ist nicht so ganz typisch.
Und das vom Alter her und bei der Vorgeschichte des Vaters
würde ich eher befürchten,
dass es sich hier um ein Kolonkarzinom handelt.
Bei Subilius bis Ilius, das werden Sie sehen,
wahrscheinlich wird bei der Rektalenuntersuchung
die Ampule nicht stuhlgefühlt sein.
Ja, gut.
Gut, aber insgesamt gesehen, denke ich,
haben Sie das sehr gut gemacht.
Die Anamnese haben Sie sehr systematisch erhoben
und nachgefragt, wenn das nicht klar war.
Vielleicht bei der Schilderung beim Oberarzt
noch etwas mehr medizinische Fachbegriffe bringen,
dass Sie zum Beispiel gesagt haben,
er hat einen geblähten Bauch.
Da sollten Sie ruhig einfließen,
Abdomen oder Meteorismus oder Neusea,
so etwas könnte vielleicht noch von Ihnen gebracht werden.
Aber insgesamt gesehen,
auch wenn wir bei der Verdachtstiagnose
etwas auseinander liegen,
fand ich das sehr gut.
Danke Ihnen.
Können wir auch eine Hemmocultest durchführen?
Ja, aber wenn Sie jetzt keinen Stuhl haben,
dann wird der Hemmocultest schwierig.
Aber das kann man probieren.
Aber ich sage, das Alter spricht eher
für einen konsumierenden Prozess,
ein Neoplasma, die Gewichtsabnahme,
veränderte Stuhlverhalten innerhalb der letzten Wochen,
schleimiger Stuhl,
das wäre so wahrscheinlich meine erste Verdachtstiagnose.
Jetzt muss er gut untersucht werden,
weil wir haben ja eine Subildos-Symptomatik
und da müssen wir aufpassen,
dass der Patient sich nicht verschlechtert.
Genau, ja.
Gut, und das Angebot, was Sie gemacht haben,
zwischendurch, dass Sie gefragt haben,
ob der Patient etwas gegen Schmerzen braucht,
das fand ich auch gut,
dass Sie sich nachgefragt haben und gekümmert haben.
Ja, passt.
Und wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Nächste Woche am Mittwoch.
Das wird gut gehen.
Danke Ihnen.